What is a plot hole?
It's a gap or an inconsistency in a storyline
that goes against the flow of logic established
by the story's plot.
These can include illogical or impossible
events, and statements or events that contradict
earlier events in the storyline.
Frankly, television is teaming with them - even
the most popular shows on the small screen
- and, in this video, we're going to run you
through just a few of them.
If you want to see more interesting videos
like this, subscribe to our channel and keep
coming back!
Here are ten plot holes in the biggest TV
shows that went unnoticed.
Sheldon's Financial Situation - The Big Bang
Theory
In The Big Bang Theory's season one episode
The Dumpling Paradox, Sheldon Cooper makes
a reference to his financial status by saying
to Leonard "Frankly, if I could afford the
rent, I'd ask you to leave," which explicitly
means he can't pay the rent on his apartment
by himself.
However, in season three's The Execlsior Acquisition,
it's shown that he's so well-off that he doesn't
even cash his pay cheques, he just leaves
them in a drawer in his desk.
Moreover, in season two's The Financial Permeability,
he lends Penny a large amount of money from
a huge stash he just happens to have lying
around, so he's obviously independently wealthy.
Which one is it, Big Bang writers?
Is Sheldon hard-up or rich?!
Olaf's Hammer - Buffy the Vampire Slayer
The character of Olaf the Troll was introduced
in the Buffy the Vampire Slayer fifth season
episode Triangle.
In that episode, it was established that he
was a former lover of Anya's, whom she had
punished for his unfaithfulness by turning
him into a troll.
Later that season, when Buffy went to fight
Glory, she used Olaf's hammer to do so - with
the reason being that, to fight a god, you
should use a god's weapon.
At no point previously had Olaf been referred
to as a god - and, given that his troll form
was actually a curse, it makes no sense whatsoever
to have described him as one.
The Friends' Ages - Friends
There were so many inconsistencies with the
main characters' ages in classic sitcom Friends
- and it's an issue that has now come to irk
fans of the show.
For example, when Ross first told Joey when
his birthday was, he said it’s in December,
but a few seasons later he claims it’s October
18th.
He was also 29-years-old for three seasons
of the show, despite going through several
Christmas and other Holiday episodes.
He wasn't the only one with age problems,
however.
In the episode The One Where They All Turn
30, the cast celebrate Rachel’s birthday,
and she's the last one to hit the milestone
- yet Joey is actually established as the
youngest.
For instance, in the early episode The One
with The Birth, he said he was 25, while Rachel
and Monica were both already 26.
Quagmire's Age - Family Guy
By its very nature, Seth MacFarlane's brilliant
Family Guy is inconsistent and silly, so a
lot of it doesn't make sense - but there's
one particular issue that can only be described
as a plot hole; Glenn Quagmire's age.
According to his driver's license in the epsiode
FOX-y Lady, Quagmire is 61-years-old and puts
his youthful appearance down to eating carrots.
However, he recounts a "youthful" sexual encounter
with Tracey Bellings in 1986 in A Fistful
of Meg, and he was at a school dance in 1984
in Meet the Quagmires.
Quagmire being so young in those years would
mean he couldn't possibly be 61 - especially
given that he was at the school dance with
Peter and Lois, who are both in their 40s.
The House Homer Grew Up In - The Simpsons
Like Family Guy, you'd be foolish to go overboard
with your criticism of plot holes in The Simpsons,
as it's just a fun animation for all the family.
However, there are some that can't be ignored.
In the episode E-I-E-I-(Annoyed Grunt), Homer
and his family flee to the farmhouse where
he grew up.
However, Homer and Grandpa had accidentally
burned the house down in the earlier episode
Grandpa vs. Sexual Inadequacy.
Inexplicably, the house is still standing
when the family arrive.
Moreover, when Homer can't grow any food there,
a neighbouring farmer tells him that's why
Grandpa Simpson abandoned the place, but in
Grandpa vs. Sexual Inadequacy, Abe said he
left because the cows started giving sour
milk.
David's Fireworks Party - Coronation Street
We now come to Great Britain's most popular
soap opera - Coronation Street - which has
been running on ITV for no less than 56 years.
Even with that amount of production experience,
the writers still get things wrong.
Take David Platt's 2016 character arc, for
example.
When David tried to commit suicide, he accidentally
set his neighbour Anna Windass on fire - and
she ended up in hospital with serious burns.
David was distraught and disappeared for a
few weeks but, when he returned to the screen,
guess what he did first?
He planned a huge fireworks party for his
kids!
That's such an out-of-character act that it
has to be described as a plot hole - and poor
writing and forgetfulness on the part of the
writers.
The Doctor's Regenerations - Doctor Who
It is a long-established fact in the Doctor
Who canon - or the Whoniverse, as it's known
- that the titular Doctor can only use his
regeneration ability thirteen times.
This has now proven to be problematic, however.
Although there have only been twelve official
Doctors - meaning he's only used eleven of
his regenerations on himself - the Doctor
has also used his regenerations to heal his
friends over the years.
Frankly, therefore, he should have run out
of them long ago.
Yet he's still going - and there's no sign
of the show slowing down, so we'll undoubtedly
get a thirteenth, fourteenth and fifteenth
Doctor, and so on.
Why Did Nobody Notice They Were Missing?
- Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
In 1993, the world was introduced to the Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers - a group of teenagers
recruited by the wizard Zordon and his robot
assistant Alpha 5 to protect the Earth - and
there was a recurring plot hole that basically
happened in every single episode.
More often than not, the Power Rangers were
contacted at school to report for duty, and
they would teleport to Zordon at his command
center.
At no point, however, did their school's faculty
notice that their star pupils were missing
classes.
It was never questioned or even addressed,
even though it happened all the time.
Warp 10 Irregularities - Star Trek
Star Trek has been around in various forms
since 1966, but there's one thing that the
writers of the TV shows can't seem to agree
on, which has resulted in a plot hole - and
that's the idea of travelling at the speed
of warp 10.
In the original 1966 series and Star Trek
the Next Generation, the Enterprise reached
warp 10 on several occasions - and all that
resulted in was the ship travelling faster
than normal.
However, in the Voyager episode Threshold,
Tom Paris achieves warp 10 and is described
as being the first human ever to have done
so.
Moreover, the ship doesn't just go faster
- Paris is also described as existing at every
point in the universe at that speed (something
that wasn't declared previously).
Michonne's Walkers - The Walking Dead
When viewers were first introduced to the
now established character of Michonne - played
by Danai Gurira - in AMC's brilliant The Walking
Dead, the character was accompanied by two
shackled walkers, who have been revealed to
be her reanimated boyfriend and his best friend.
She used them for camouflage and was able
to walk amongst other walkers because of their
presence next to her.
But why?
It is established that walkers can smell living
humans and there's no viable explanation as
to why Michonne would be able to avoid detection
just because she had two of them next to her.
Thanks for watching our video about ten plot
holes in the biggest TV shows that went unnoticed.
Did you enjoy this video?
Can you think of any other gaping holes in
the plots of major TV shows?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.